a new bipartisan report from the senate  was released earlier this morning  it says law enforcement should have been  better prepared for the january 6th  assault on the u.s  capitol this report says capital  intelligence saw a social media post  as far back as december about a plot to  breach the capitol  that included maps of the buildings and  tunnels  along with threats against congress  members the report added the capitol  police intelligence division did not  convey the full  scope of known information to leadership  or to law enforcement  part of the reason it was overlooked is  people were saying well this just can't  happen  and these groups of folks they can't do  that well now we know they can  the report is the result of a joint  investigation by the senate homeland  security and rules committee  it also mentions former president  trump's speech to his supporters  that morning of january 6 but did not  address  specific root causes of that attack